are you okay having all these white
people crashing Wakanda are you okay
with that
you know the beauty is that you know I
got I got a step-by-step experience you
know first you know it came came Winter
Soldier then we got you know the
wonderful martin freeman coming in the
standalone so you know she's it's been
it's been a step-by-step process so now
you know the guess who's coming to
dinner should i know who's coming to
dinner I just feel like suddenly it's
like where were all of you five years
ago you don't I mean it's Conan O'Brien
I'm hearing what Conda and you're like
come on no it's all right you know we we
opened ourselves up to the world we got
rules we got regulations we got table
man or you know etiquette stuff that we
teach them as they come in you don't
look at me when you're wonderful good I
saved your ass several times there are
none of you have seen the movie yet
there was so much secrecy around these
movies that they distributed fake
scripts to some of you that would enrage
me if I started learning lines and then
found out later on that its fate and it
doesn't really line up with what's
really happening in the movie you're all
gonna see it for the first time is that
tomorrow yeah you wear that yeah okay
just found out you're going on man yeah
[Laughter]
you thought we were playing iron mill
yeah yeah I was like oh cool I'm dumb
yeah I can do all things yeah you're
aware though that is now a Western
primarily musical westerns yes
[Music]
you